[MUSIC PLAYING]
HANAN YOUSSEF: Hello.
Welcome to our session.
This is Choosing the Right
Google Compute Engine Instance
Type for Your Workload.
My name is Hanan Youssef.
I'm a product manager on
Google Compute Engine,
and today during
the session I'll
be walking you through the
different virtual-machine types
available on our platform as
well as the new infrastructure
announcements that we're
making today during Next 2019
I'll focus on describing
the different options
available to you,
the capabilities
of the new instance
types and the new VMs,
and also will walk
through some guidelines
to help you make decisions about
the right VM infrastructure
for your workload.
I hope that by the
end of the session
you will have a clearer picture
of the different VM types
available, and I hope
you will find it easier
to pick the right
infrastructure for any workload
that you bring to Google Cloud.
Before we start, we want
to let you know that we
do have a Dory for the session.
So please feel free to go
to their Next application
and add any questions
you have for us.
We'll have some time to
answer any questions you
have in the Dory at
the end of the session.
So let's start by talking
about the applications
that you are running
today on the cloud.
I'm sure if I asked
this room, we'll
come up with a list of a hundred
or possibly more different
application types,
different workloads,
and different
architectures that you're
looking to run on GCP or
in your cloud provider.
Some of you might be focused
on running high-performance web
applications.
Others might be looking
for ways to run your ERP
systems efficiently
in the cloud,
or maybe you're simply
looking for the ability
to [INAUDIBLE] to the
cloud and finish a job
that you have at the moment
that you're thinking about,
a batch job.
So how easy do you
find the process
of matching your needs to
the capabilities provided
by your cloud provider?
Do you find it easy
to find the right VM
type at the right cost
with the right performance
in the right locations
that you're looking at?
Do you find it
sometimes confusing
to look through a very big and
large catalog of instance types
with different features
and capabilities
and find it difficult
to compare them?
I bet you do.
I personally sometimes
find it very confusing
to look through all of
these options available.
I think one thing
that also makes this
a more complex question
for us to answer
is the fact that your workloads
are typically not stable.
What you start with
might need to change.
Your performance
requirements might change.
Your budget might change.
And we need to figure
out how easy it
is for you to make these
changes as you get them.
We believe that this
should be simple.
This is why in GCP
from day one we really
focused on taking a
very different approach
to our instance types.
We understand that
you need simplicity
so that your decision making
is easy and effective without
requiring you to have
a PhD in our catalog
or study that for hours.
We know that you
need flexibility
because your needs change
because your requirements come
up every day-- new requirements
come up every day as you
provide workload or
as your business grows
and you need
different requirements
or different
resources, for example.
We've also
prioritized efficiency
as one thing we
always look at when
trying to introduce
new capabilities
into our infrastructure.
And efficiency is very important
over here because on the cloud
you shouldn't need to overbuy.
You shouldn't need
to overprovision.
You should find
something that fits
exactly what you're
looking for and what
you're going to benefit from.
So let's look at this
process in more details.
How do you actually pick the
right VM shape on Google Cloud?
How do you match
your exact needs
to that available
from our platform?
We believe that for
90% of your workloads
this should be a very
simple process where
you need to do no
comparisons and you
need to find what you're looking
for with exactly one click.
And this is why
we've really focused
on having that as one
of our core pillars
as we created our
general-purpose VM.
We wanted to make them
simply truly general purpose.
They are designed to
be simple, flexible,
and fit the majority
of your workload,
and we do that in many ways.
First of all, we focus with
our general-purpose VMs
on giving you flexible sizing.
You can simply choose
the number of cores
and the amount of memory that
you need at any point of time
and with the ratio that
you're looking for.
You don't have to choose from
only predefined shapes which
might map to some
workloads we have
in mind that might
not necessarily
be exactly what
you're looking for.
With the general-purpose
machine types,
you can choose more
memory, more cores,
or you can choose a balance.
And what's very
important in this process
is that you don't
need to think or worry
about price changing
in strange ways
as you change those ratios.
So by having a very
simple and linear pricing
for both cores and memory,
that becomes one less decision
you need to think
about and one less
factor you need to consider.
It's one simple pricing that
you can have across the board.
What's also very important about
the general-purpose machine
types is that with
the custom machine
types available on
Google Cloud Platform,
right sizing becomes something
that you can actually
do on the cloud so that
you don't overprovision
and you get exactly
what you're looking for.
Let's talk about
custom machine types.
As you can see
here, these sliders
are actually part of what I
like most about Google Compute
Engine, simple sliders that
allow you to just configure
the machine type to
what you have in mind
and what exactly fits
what you're looking at.
With custom machine types,
you can build an exact fit,
and you can prevent
any wasted resources.
And we've seen our
customers use this feature
to actually benefit from more
than 19% savings versus just
using predefined instances
that are available, including
predefined instances available
on Google Compute Engine
itself.
Another great way that
custom machine types
help you is that it provides
you with something that we
call extended memory,
and extended memory
is really meant to
break any barriers
you have to creating the
exact shape you're looking at.
So for example,
let's take an example
of a workload that
has very expensive
per-core requirements.
On any cloud, you typically
have to choose the memory
that you're looking
for, and you get
a predefined amount of
cores available with that,
and then you will have to
pay the licensing for all
your cores.
You don't have any choice.
With extended memory,
you can actually
figure out the amount
of memory that you need
and then decrease
the number of cores
that you're buying with the
VM so that you don't have
to wait to pay for
extra licensing
that you don't actually need.
Another great thing about
custom machine types and about
the general-purpose
VMs is that we're also,
aside from giving
you the ability
to create the exact shape
that you're looking for,
we also try to help
you with that decision
and help you with
figuring out what
the right number and
the right fit is.
We do this through the
rightsizing recommendations.
So if you've been on the
Google Cloud console recently,
you might have seen a screen
that looks like this one,
and what this screen shows
you is our own recommendation
and the platform intelligence
that we make available to you
so that you can figure out
if what you're running today
is really the most efficient
way to run your workload.
On the top here, for example,
I have an eight vCPU VM
that I'm not fully utilizing.
And because of that, Google
Compute Engine right away
gives me a recommendation
that I can actually
downsize to a different VM and
directly save more than $150
per month.
In many ways, this is meant
to give you the ability
so that with custom
machine types
and with the rightsizing
recommendation
you get the exact
fit and you avoid
overspending on infrastructure
resources that you don't need.
Another thing which is
really significant and great
about general-purpose
VMs is that they give you
a lot of flexibility to change
the attachments that you
add to those VMs.
A great example is storage.
So on a typical day you might
think coming into the cloud
that you need locally
attached storage
to be able to get the
performance that you're
looking for.
Maybe a few days later after
some performance testing
you see that you actually don't
need all that performance,
and you prefer to
have something that's
network attached and more
durable for your critical data.
In a typical case,
you would have
had to change your
entire VM type,
choose a different one that
has local storage or not
local storage.
With Google Compute
Engine, we try
to make that a
much easier process
so that you can just
have a VM running on GCE
and go and change the storage
mode or the storage type
that you are using with this VM.
As you can see here, you
can choose the local SSD;
you can choose persistent disk,
which is network attached;
and you can even choose
among the different types
of persistent attached disks
that are available to you.
The main goal of thinking about
our infrastructure this way
and presenting it this
way is that we simplify
the process of decision making
and we simplify the process
of operations for you.
This applies to a lot of things
across Google Compute Engine.
A couple of examples
have to do with how we
manage CPU platforms and GPUs.
We simply believe that
there are decisions
you shouldn't have
to spend time on,
and there are things
that an intelligent cloud
platform should be able to
do automatically for you.
One clear example is managing
the hardware upgrade cycle.
Maybe for some of
your workloads you
do care about understanding
the underlying CPU architecture
and optimizing your code for it.
You might be using certain
instruction sets, for example.
However, from our
experience we've
seen that most of
the time you actually
don't need to worry
about that and you
don't need to think about it.
You just need something
that runs and runs well
on the cloud.
And for these cases,
we give you the ability
to choose a minimum
CPU platform.
As you see in the screen
under CPU Platform,
this is Intel Skylake or later.
And what that means is that
by simply choosing this box
and choosing that option
you give us the ability
to manage the hardware
upgrade cycle on your behalf
so that we can
continue to move you
to the more recent
infrastructure,
more efficient
infrastructure as this
becomes the most appropriate
one for us to use
and for you to use without you
having to go and do any work.
You don't stop the instance.
You don't recreate another one.
It simply upgrades
on your behalf.
If we're talking
about flexibility,
another thing that
we believe helps you
with general-purpose
VMs is the ability
to choose different
accelerator types.
You might have been
using K80s, for example,
at a certain point of time
with now one experiment
with the new T4 GPUs.
You don't need to go and rebuild
your entire infrastructure.
Again, you can remove
one GPU and add another,
and you're set to go without
having to go back and figure
out if, for example, the
perfect shape that you've
been recommended also exists
with the GPU instances.
So to summarize for the
general-purpose VMs,
we covered how a wide variety
of options and of workloads
are available with those
general-purpose VMs.
We talked about
how they enable you
to run things that
might be very different
and have different resource
requirements by changing
the amount of cores
and memory that you
have available across different
workloads from databases
to web applications, mobile
gaming, and dev and test
environments.
We also discussed
the great flexibility
you get with
general-purpose VMs.
You don't have to spend a lot
of time trying to research
or compare the instances.
You get custom
machine types which
enable you to create an
exact fit for your workloads.
And even if finding the exact
fit is not a right task,
you get recommendations
that enable you to do that.
This makes general-purpose
VMs great for a wide variety
of workloads and makes them
really a very simple way
to get started without
having to rethink or to look
through a very large catalog
of instance-types options
and compare them.
We've seen our customers make
great benefit of these features
and these capabilities
and tell us
a lot of times how custom
machine types really
enable them to
change their economy,
to change the economy of
running their infrastructure,
and spend their money and their
focus on their operations,
on what really matters.
Now let's talk about
bursty workloads.
Many Google Cloud customers
look for a better option
to run more cost-sensitive and
bursty jobs when they need to.
This can be the kind
of job where you just
need to run thousands
of cores, for example,
for a very short period
of time on the cloud
so that you complete a
certain task you have in mind.
A good example here is
rendering jobs, for example.
We see a lot of
studios coming to GCP.
So they run a long-running,
a big rendering job,
get the task done in a
very short period of time
by leveraging thousands
of VMs at one time.
Typically these workloads
only care about the time
it takes for them to complete.
They might not essentially
care about this
being a real-time
process where they
are interacting
with their customer
in every step of the way.
And I'm sure that
you would agree
that the economics become a
very big part of this decision.
When you're looking to run
tens of thousands of VMs
for a short period
of time, you really
don't want to be spending
too much for that.
For these cases, preemptible VMs
is GCP's recommended solution.
Preemptible VMs are made
for batch, checkpointed,
and high-throughput computing.
They are simply short-run VMs
that can run for up to 24 hours
and can be preempted
at any point of time.
And with those
constraints, they become
80% cheaper for you to run.
The great thing
about these VM types
is that they are actually
not a separate VM type.
It's just a flag that you
can add to any instance
at any point of time.
You don't have to go
and redo your research
or think about some capabilities
you might be missing
if you chose preemptible
VMs, for example.
This makes them ideal for
a variety of workloads,
from genomics to computational
chemistry to data processing
and simulations.
The greatest thing about them
is that you get directly 80%
off which is a fixed discount.
You get predictable
pricing without having
to face any unpredictability
into this process.
As long as you have jobs
that are fault tolerant
and can manage preemption,
you directly get this benefit.
Again, we've seen many
GCP customers make
great use of this capability.
Many of them run tens
of thousands of cores
and tens of thousands
of VMs while saving
money, an equation,
which is typically not
very easy to solve.
Now let's move to a
different workload.
Let's talk about
gaming as an example.
Multiplayer games specifically
are a great example
of a compute-intensive workload.
We see typically
AAA titles looking
for the fastest and
best experience they can
present to their end customers.
For these companies,
frame-processing time
is critical.
If that ended up happening
slower than expected,
then their players, the
gamers, would actually
notice that their game is
not performing as expected,
and it would impact
their experience.
This is why we've been
working for a very long time
on introducing the new
Compute-Optimized VMs, which
is one of the new instance
types that we've announced today
during Next 2019.
Compute-Optimized VMs
simply provide the highest
per-core performance on GCP.
They are the best fit for
compute-intensive workloads.
That might include AAA gaming,
high-performance computing,
and a lot of very
high-performance websites
and applications.
These instances
provide more than 40%
higher performance for
workloads that are compute bound
and care about
single-threaded perf.
What's great about those VMs is
that with this new introduction
they are actually powered by
the latest CPU architecture
available on the market.
So these are powered by
the new Intel Scalable
processors, the second
generation, codenamed Cascade
Lake, and they offer the highest
frequency available on GCP
with up to 3.8 gigahertz
in all-core-turbo.
Let's talk a little bit more
about Compute-Optimized VMs.
As you can see, they already
come with multiple shapes
and options.
So today they range
from 4 to 60 vCPUs,
from 16 to 240 gigabytes
of memory, offering you
a four to one gigabyte
per vCPU ratio.
They also enable
you to manage or use
multiple storage options.
So you can use network-attached
storage, persistent disk,
or you can use local
SSD, local storage,
as with any other GCE instance.
We're also happy that we
are introducing these VMs
with the new
networking caps that we
have available that
were announced today.
So they offer directly up
to 32 gigabits per second.
And going beyond the
shapes and the hardware,
we've really focused on making
the Compute-Optimized VMs
the best option for you when you
have near-real-time and highly
demanding workloads.
So these VMs, you
get full transparency
into the underlying hardware.
You get explicit
NUMA visibility so
that you get the
best performance
across the different VM
types and different VM sizes.
You also get very
tight consistency
and very predictable
performance so
that you can bet your most
intensive applications
on those VMs.
For those of you
that are looking
to do more fine tuning
of your performance,
you'll also get access to things
such as the processor power
state so that you can fine tune
your application performance
on those VMs.
So to summarize what we covered
for Compute-Optimized VMs,
these are one of our
new introductions
to GCP as we look to cover
more of the edge cases
that you might have for
your different workloads.
They have the highest
performance per core
available on Google
Compute Engine.
They are powered by the
latest Intel second-generation
Scalable processors and
go up to 3.8 gigahertz
in all-core-turbo.
In addition, they have
minimal variability, very high
consistency, and offer
you multiple shapes
so that you can find the one
thing which is looking for
and fits your workload.
This makes them a great fit
for multiple applications,
including multiplayer gaming,
high-performance computing,
video encoding, real-time
web serving, and others.
Now let's move to some of
the other highly demanding
workloads-- different types
of highly demanding workloads.
One great example here might
be databases, specifically
high-end databases.
We see a lot of customers
running large ERP systems--
for example, SAP ERP systems.
And what they are
looking for typically
is the fact that as their
database continues to grow,
they are looking for
an infrastructure that
will grow with them and will be
able to scale with their needs.
While they think
about this, they
are also looking for
an infrastructure that
continues to give them
the benefits of running
on the cloud, the flexibility
that comes with that,
and the ability to have
higher fault tolerance
and many of the great
features that we talked about.
This is where the
Memory-Optimized VMs
come into the picture.
And the way we really define
Memory-Optimized VMs on Google
Compute Engine is that
they are the large memory
VMs, 1 terabyte and higher.
These typically tend to be
multiple-socket systems, very
large systems, and tend to have
a very high amount of memory
per core so that they
can continue to scale
with your memory needs.
Memory-Optimized VMs are built
for memory-intensive workloads,
including in-memory databases
and in-memory analytics.
They provide the highest
gigabyte per core
available on GCP with options
that range from 15 to 24
or 25 gigabytes per
vCPU, and they also
offer you the lowest
dollar per gigabyte
available with these
configurations.
Multiple shapes are
available for you
under the Memory-Optimized
VM category
ranging from 1.5 terabytes
up to the 6- and 12-terabyte
VMs that we just announced today
and with plans to even extend
up to 18 terabytes and more.
If you're thinking about how
the infrastructure continues
to scale with your database
and scale with your needs,
then one of the things
we've really had as one
of our guiding
principles for those VMs
is the speed at which we've
been trying to add new sizes
and continue to scale
with your requirements.
So you can see here that in
approximately the last 18
months, those VMs have increased
in sizing by more than 10x
for the number of
cores they provide
and 60x for the amount of
memory available on those VMs.
My favorite part about
Memory-Optimized VMs
though is that they
continue to give you
all the benefits of
Google Compute Engine
that we've just described.
So they are fully flexible,
and they provide you
with very high availability.
Let's talk about availability.
With Memory-Optimized
VMs, you continue
to get live migration supporting
zero downtime for your most
critical applications.
And for those of you not
familiar with live migration,
it's simply our
way of making sure
that maintenance events are
transparent to your workloads.
When Google Cloud expects
or sees that a maintenance
event is about to
happen, we transparently
spin up another
version of your VM,
copy all the data
over so that you
don't have to
experience any downtime
or impact on your application.
And this continues to
be one of the things
that we keep as a core
part of infrastructure
as we expand to more sizes.
Another thing here
is flexibility.
If you're running the
type of deployment
and the type of workload where
you expect your requirements
to change months over
months, then you definitely
don't want to be stuck
into a reserved size
where moving to a different size
requires a different contract
or a different commitment.
And this is why the
commitments that we provide
for Memory-Optimized
VMs are really just
for Memory-Optimized VMs.
You can use the same
commitment for a 1-terabyte VM.
You can add to that and
use it for 4-terabyte VMs,
or you can divide it across
different VMs as you scale out
or scale up.
It's really up to you.
It's one big category
that you can divide it
the way you see fit as you
scale up or as you scale down.
Another great thing about
Memory-Optimized VMs
is the simplicity.
These are native GCP VMs, native
Google Compute Engine VMs.
They fully support all the
Google Compute Engine features
and capabilities.
You use them directly from
the console, from G Cloud,
from the API.
You can use labels.
You can use any other features
that you're using today,
including the policies, for
example, that you have defined
for your organizations
and manage them exactly
as any other small VM available
as part of your deployment.
The last part I mention about
the Memory-Optimized VMs
is our focus on
making sure that we
introduce new innovation as we
continue to expand our sizing.
A great example of that is the
support for the latest memory
technologies, and you
might have recently seen
some announcements from
Google Compute Engine
where we talked about the Intel
Optane DC persistent memory.
This technology is specifically
useful for those of you
who have been seeing
a gap between the cost
and the performance available
from DRAM and that available
from flash or from SSD.
If you have applications that
require better performance than
storage but you cannot afford
to have them running on DRAM due
to the cost
associated with that,
then this fits into
that gap over there.
As you can see, it
fits in that place
between memory and storage.
The other great thing
about this technology
is that it also gives you the
availability or the ability
to have persistent memory so
that for certain applications
the application going down
doesn't mean that you actually
lose all of your data,
even though you get
the performance or a performance
that's very close to that you
get with DRAM.
Google Cloud has done a lot of
early work with this technology
and focused on availing it
first so that you can test it
on our platform.
With that, we give you
much higher density per VM
than that which can only be
available with the regular
memory technologies--
approximately 4x more memory
at significantly lower cost.
It tends to be much faster
and lower latency than storage
and is a great fit for in-memory
databases across the board.
Today, we do have in our
alpha testing programs
a few shapes available
where you can
test Intel DC persistent
memory for yourself
and add with a small node,
with a 96-vCPU node, up to 6.7
terabyte across DRAM and
Optane DC persistent memory.
If you have workloads
where you don't
need the performance
of DRAM and you
want to leverage the
TCO improvements,
this might be a great
fit for your testing.
So let's summarize the different
instance types we've covered.
We talked about how with
Google Compute Engine
you get very flexible
general-purpose VMs.
General-purpose VMs tend
to be the most flexible
and the most simple to use.
They are great for a
wide range of workloads
across web serving,
databases, gaming, and others.
They also give you the ability
to rightsize the VM to exactly
what you're looking for.
You get recommendations
that help you
with making sure that you're
picking the right size.
They are very
flexible and enable
you to directly attach or
detach accelerators or storage
options.
Then we covered the
Compute-Optimized VMs,
one of the new things
that we're introducing
on Google Compute Engine for
your very performance-intensive
workloads.
Compute-Optimized VMs offer the
highest performance per core
available on GCP.
They are a great
fit for AAA gaming,
HPC, high-performance
websites, and some types
of scientific modeling.
They are available
in multiple shapes
and enable you to get
approximately 3.8 gigahertz
in all-core-turbo.
We talked about
Memory-Optimized VMs,
and these VMs are a great
fit for your memory-intensive
workloads.
They have a lot of
sizes that go from 1
terabyte to approximately
12 terabytes
today, with more coming.
They are a great fit
for high-end databases,
in-memory databases, as well
as real-time and in-memory
analytics.
They also offer you
great flexibility
since you can always
scale up or scale down
or divide your commitments
across them in different shapes
and sizes.
We also talked about
preemptible VMs,
which is really a simple flag
that you can add to any VM type
across the different
types we talked about
regardless of your CPU
and memory and performance
requirements.
And once you add that
flag, you automatically
get the most economic option
for bursty, fault-tolerance
workloads.
This is a great fit if
you're running a rendering
job, a batch job,
or some simulations
that you just need compute for
but you don't care if it gets
preempted and then
continues to run again,
and you have that
kind of intelligence
into your platform.
So to summarize,
today we really focus
on how we can make some of
your decision making simpler
on Google Compute Engine by
making sure that we always
continue to focus on simplicity,
flexibility, and efficiency.
We talked about how you
can use simple guidelines
to make simple choices
on whether you just
want a wide range
of flexible options
with general-purpose
VMs or you're
looking for the most
performant option
available with
Compute-Optimized VMs.
We also covered how, for some
of your very memory-intensive
applications, with
memory-optimized shapes
you get the benefits of
the cloud with the sizing
that you're looking for, and you
get a lot of benefits related
to availability and
flexibility even
as you go to these large sizes.
We hope that that gives
you a general overview
into the options
available for you
and makes it a little
bit easier to decide
on what you're looking for
on Google Compute Engine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]